hey Cowboys are you ready for Red Dead
Redemption too will have to wait just a
bit longer than expected but at least we
have a release date now I'm Tony and
this GameSpot news update will tell you
what you need to know Rockstar Games
confirmed that Red Dead Redemption 2 is
coming to ps4 and Xbox one on October
26th the game was originally supposed to
launch this spring after being moved out
of fall 2017 Rockstar apologized for the
new delay saying the extra time is
needed for more game polish along with
the new date come new screenshots and
they do look pretty sweet the last we
saw of Red Dead Redemption 2 was the
game's story trailer which introduced us
to protagonist Arthur Morgan he's a
member of the vanderlin gang who are set
to quote rob fight and steal their way
across the vast and rugged heart of
America in order to survive there's no
word on a PC release at this time but we
do have a breakdown of that story
trailer on GameSpot if you really want
to dig into what each scene could be
teasing
[Music]